riant noir léonard sors de ta main avec
jallet une bien bonne à te raconter à
léonard
mais il n'est pas là or quel dommage
alors un jeu horreur de me retrouver
seul quand je rentre chez moi tout ce
que c'est que ça c'est une lettre de
léonard qu
casimir une fois de plus tu t'es moquer
de moi enfin mais c'est pas vrai
que tu a renversé ton peau d'orange
assure mme amal tout a coulé à
l'intérieur mes affaires sont tous taché
est collé si tu continues à agir comme
cela tu n'auras plus un seul ami c'est
moi qui te le dis salut léonard ça alors
cela me met ses terres il enfin je ne
veux pas rester sans amis mois
il léonard a certainement raison parce
que j'ai remarqué que depuis quelque
temps le facteur ix et monsieur du snav
n'était plus très gentil avec moi en toi
je veux avoir des amis il faut que je
fasse quelque chose j'ai une idée je
voudrais commencer par téléphoné à
monsieur travelling
[Musique]
voilà j'arrive n'arrive pas
ce travail nous sommes ravis de vous
voir viendrait dire personne ne savait
si
tout le monde mais pas de votre avis est
ce cher en artiste de kazemi doit être
impatient de signer le nouveau contrat
que je viens de lui préparer là dans ma
poche comment monsieur trà vinh vous
aviez déclaré que vous renonciez à
promener casimir dans une cage à
l'horrible gros monstre on aimerait en
effet mam'zelle j'avais renoncé mais
casimir a dû réfléchir et m'a téléphoné
ce matin à grisy d'urgence et de lui
apporter un contrat d'artiste de musique
artiste de music-hall mes pneus j'en
reviens pas il a perdu la tête il doit
rêver certainement d'entendre les foules
en délire l'arabe à vrai dire monsieur
travelling je n'ai encore jamais vu de
spectateurs applaudir un monstre en 15
mois n'ont plus foi ton truc mais classé
mire de cette poule b ce même ce
travelling vous croyez devenu y est
sincère mais voyons voyons ne soyez pas
déçus n'est pas question de promener
casimir dans une cage mais s'il veut
faire du music-hall je suis prêt à
l'aider sincèrement a débuté sur les
planches c'est à dire sur la scène quoi
mais ce n'est pas casimir qui va faire
ses débuts sur les planches petit
travelling mais vous le dire eh bien
regardez plutôt cette affiche que
casimir m'a demandé de placarder dans le
jardin aujourd'hui grande conférence sur
l'amitié par casimir participation
d'artistes une conférence sur l'amitié
c'est formidable je ne comprends pas
quels sont ces artistes dont il annonce
sa participation et bien c'est vous
laissez moi
non mais écoutez c'est pourtant simple
vous vous souvenez de notre petite
chance notre chemin hors
plaisance non pas du tout et elle a même
beaucoup plus la quasi nul comme c'est
une chanson sur l'année qui désirent que
nous la champions pendant sa conférence
c'est une très bonne y achète cet avis
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai beaucoup
de talent je comprends votre en tout ca
fait bien je vais me suis moi-même un
contrat et je sens très bon dans la
conférence de calais
puisque j'arrive au terme de cette
conférence sur l'amitié je voulais vous
dire encore une fois quand et gaullistes
finit toujours par être malheureux
nous ne pouvons pas nous passer d'amis
et même si ceux ci ne sont pas parfaits
nous devons faire des efforts pour les
comprendre
avant de terminer je voudrais laisser la
parole à de grands artistes qui eux
mêmes ont beaucoup souffert du manque
d'amitié ils vont vous interpréter une
chanson j'ai nommé mademoiselle aide
mais [ __ ] avons les monsieur albert
aveline ya
ces grands artistes vont vous chantez le
kango de l'amitié mais jamie après
[Applaudissements]
j'ai couru le monde entier
je voulais être milliardaire
l'argent je le modèle non pas des chats
je me croyais l'admirer
mais grâce à vous j'ai compris qu'on ne
peut vivre solitaire chacun me destin de
moi on se méfiait c'était tout seul et
je souffre à rien de voter à nouveau
c'est moi qui vous le dit adieu solitude
ici je veux rester
votre amitié me plaît gardez moi s'il
vous plaît
je ferai du pauvre pour chasser mais les
faux c'est une certitude
il faut tout partagé parfois dix ans de
règne
[Musique]
rien n'est plus beau que l'ami type
voulait et sans pitié
que l'enfance et tous mes caprices du
poteau j'ai décidé jamais je ne cédais
et je me croyais respecter
mais tous les gens redoutaient
ma poignée de main est très seul
lorsque j'approchais chacun se
détournaient personne ne me saluer rien
ne vaut des familles c'est moi qui vous
le dit
agulla solitude
u2
je veux rester votre amitié me plaît
gardez moi s'il vous plaît
je ferai ce qu'il faut pour chasser mes
défauts c'est une certitude
il faut tout partager et par du bois et
centrer
rien n'est plus beau que l'amitié rien
ne vaut des amis
moi qui voulais dire adieu la solitude
ici je veux rester recrutiez nos plaies
moi s'il vous plaît
je ferai ce qu'il faut pour chasser
défaut c'est une certitude
il faut tout partagé parfois des 113
rien n'est plus beau que l'amitié
[Rires]
maintenant commander à prend soin de
nous faire un petit discours
est-ce que vous insistez je vous dirais
quelques mots d'ailleurs je les avais
préparé
je tiens d'abord à m'adresser à julie en
votre nom à tous grâce à elle nous avons
dégusté une excellente limonade
et bien je vous remercie parce que moi
j'ai été très heureux de pouvoir
participer à cette campagne dont casimir
est l'auteur je veux aussi être adressée
à monsieur albert tremblay admet moselle
et les futaies et les féliciter
chaudement pour l'heure très très jolie
chanson
ennemis bien elle est tellement
énergique elle n'a pas pu attendre elle
est partie tout de suite préparer la
campagne de l'amitié formidable moi je
veux simplement vous dire mon nom et en
celui de moselle futé que l'on comprend
le sens de l'amitié lorsqu'on a vécu
pendant très très longtemps tout seul et
nous vous remercions tous les deux de
nous avoir donné la vo
maintenant je vais maintenant regretter
l'absence de leonard de monsieur du snob
et de emile campagne notre facteur qui
ce matin de très bonne heure sont partis
ensemble à l'appel et puis et puis enfin
enfin je m'adressais aux héros de la
journée j'ai nommé casimir
casimir mon vieux je suis heureux et je
suis fier que cette grande idée soit
l'acte i am rich il est toujours bon de
rappeler l'importance de l'amitié la
solitude est quelque chose de terrible
nous pensons tous comme toi casimir
qu'il est très important de rechercher
ce qui manque d'amis qu'est il a
constaté nous sommes tous très hâte et
d'aimer casimir je voudrais te poser la
question qui nous brûle à tous élèves
des spas casimir quels sont les gens
auxquels je voudrais que nous portions
notre amitié est bien à moi
la générosité casimir tu as gardé son
sens de l'humour c'est formidable
linou quelles sont ces gens si
malheureux qui t'ont inspiré cette
campagne mais enfin il s'agit bien de
moi je suis le seul ici à avoir besoin
d'amis c'est sûr il est absolument et
bien écoute casimir si tu te manque
encore de tes amis comme ça tu n'en
n'aura bientôt plus venez les enfants
des attendait mais qu'un membre d'un
parti par
ça alors ils ont aussi mauvais caractère
coller au nar
quand je suis malheureux à l'eau
et casimir casimir mon vieux mais
c'était une blague pas eu mais on va
passer c'est tout ce nous sommes des
amis général